I was reading a detail that I really
appreciated you wouldn't let your boys
play football they played a myriad of
other sports but you wanted them to be
grown enough to be physically strong to
take a hit and that the coaches were
really on top of their stuff you know
wait until they're old enough may I ask
do you have any mom advice for me on how
to raise good kids oh the biggest thing
for me you know especially that you
learn through Sports is to be inclusive
treat everybody the same way and let
them be The Driver of what they want to
do if you're in music or art or whatever
they have to be driving it they can't be
the parent
understood thank you Donna I so
appreciate it and Donna we love you and
we're rooting for both
[Applause]
boys
in the Super Bowl which I know with
their childhood dream